et ils vont très rapidement donc devenir
amant tout le monde le sait sauf Joël en
effet Nathalie Desprez précise que son
mari Joël n'était au courant de rien
l'information paraît d'autant plus
incroyable aux enquêteurs qu'ils
découvrent que le mari et l'amant ne se
partagait pas seulement la même femme
nous sommes le 5 février 2000 près de
Cergy en banlieue parisienne
en cette fin d'après-midi deux hommes
terminent leur partie de chasse
il rentre chez eux en marchant sur le
chemin de halage le chemin qui longe les
bords de l'Oise
[Musique]
tout doucement avec mon cousin sur le
chemin de halal ils ont un chien qui est
en train de
divaguer dans les bosquets qui sont qui
sont aux alentours
un moment donné ce chien marque l'arrêt
devant un espèce de trou qui s'est formé
dans un terrain tout proche le chien a
fait une réaction bizarre
[Musique]
ça fait que ça m'a fait attiré
l'attention j'ai monté le talus pour
voir ce que c'était pour les chasseurs
Solène fait aucun doute leur chien vient
de flairer un animal il saisisse leur
arme ça arrive prête à tirer je croyais
que c'était un sanglier ou Arna ou un
truc comme ça une nuisible ou que je
vous quand je monte le talus je me
prépare ce qui est un peu partout je
vois rien puis je coup bah je vous
baisse la tête
et au fond de ce trou il distingue une
masse ça allait surprend un peu ça
paraît une masse brûlée les deux
chasseurs repèrent alors une forme
étrange entourée de l'embout de tissus
brûlés
[Musique]
il bouge avec un bout de ferraille là
pour voir ce que c'est mais j'étais pas
sûr à 100% avec bon voyage
c'était impressionnant
en s'approchant à moins d'un mètre l'un
des chasseurs croit distinguer une forme
humaine c'est le corps d'un homme le
corps d'un homme brûlé
très largement brûlé les deux chasseurs
alertent immédiatement la police de leur
macabre découvertes
[Musique]
une fois sur place les enquêteurs
isolent la scène de crime
les policiers la pompiers tout le monde
a rien un peu sur place la nuit tombe il
faut allumer des projecteurs pour pour
éclairer la scène et faire les premiers
prélèvements et très vite les premières
constatations laissent penser que la
dépouille a été volontairement embrassée
le corps a probablement été aspergé
d'essence pour être enflammé parce qu'il
y a des traces une odeur etc qui qui
émane du cadavre le corps n'est qu'à
moitié carbonisé les enquêteurs en
déduisent que seul une faible quantité
d'essence a été utilisée et comme aucun
bidon n'est retrouvé aux alentours la
piste du suicide écarté tout laisse
penser qu'il s'agit d'un crime barbare
on a le sentiment d'être dans devant une
tombe inachevée qui n'a pas été un corps
qui n'a pas été ensevelie les hommes de
la brigade criminelle prélève plusieurs
indices pour tenter d'élucider ce
meurtre atroce
[Musique]
sur le cadavre ils vont saisir les
chaussures qui sont maculées debout et
ils vont également prélever de la terre
qui se trouve sur les lieux du crime sur
la les lieux de la découverte du crime
on trouve également dans ses vêtements
carbonisés un téléphone portable très
abîmé
inutilisable une main gauche s'est
détachée du corps la main gauche porte
une alliance la victime serait donc
mariée et au vu de ses vêtements il
s'agirait d'un homme seulement les
policiers ne trouvent aucun papier
d'identité ni détail permettant
d'identifier le corps
toutefois un élément leur fournit une
information précieuse une montre
également est à son poignet et cette
montre est arrêtée à deux heures quinze
la découverte de cette montre et de leur
arrêtée nous laisse peut nous laisser
penser que c'est le moment où le corps
s'est embrasé ou du moins ou la mort est
intervenue le meurtre aurait donc eu
lieu aux alentours de 2h15 mais
impossible de savoir s'il s'agit du
matin ou de l'après-midi pour le moment
finalement c'est un simple morceau de
papier retrouvé dans la poche de la
victime qui va interpeller les policiers
lessive assouplissant fleur de pêche et
lait
et donc cet individu on sait qu'il
devait faire des courses qu'il a dû
faire des courses et acheter quand même
ce qui ressemble bien à ce qu'on achète
quand on a une famille
qui est ce père de famille qui a été
assassiné alors qu'il partait faire ses
courses le mystère ne fait que commencer
comme il est d'usage dans ces cas-là les
inspecteurs élargissent leurs recherches
à l'ensemble du secteur et ils seront de
compte immédiatement que leur tâches
s'annoncent très compliquées donc on est
dans un endroit complètement isolé en
fait
aucune habitation à proximité
l'habitation la plus proche et entre 500
et 800 mètres on est dans une zone de
chasse en fait et ce qui explique que ce
soit des chasseurs qui est découvert
découvert le corps les voisins les plus
proches n'ont rien vu les joggers et les
promenons non plus il y a bien des
traces de pneus mais ont-elles été
laissées par le ou les meurtriers
difficile à ce stade de l'affirmer
d'autant que les policiers sont
confrontés à un obstacle qui a fait la
une de l'actualité quelques jours plus
tôt 13 jours après la tempête qui a
causé de nombreux dégâts dans les forêts
domaniales de la région leur est au
bilan de nombreux travaux de dégagement
des arbres ont été effectués par les
agents de l'Office National des Forêts
notamment aux environs de Chantilly le
26 décembre 19
le nord de la France a été touché par
l'une des plus grosses tempêtes du
siècle une partie des forêts a été
décimée et pour les enquêteurs c'est un
sérieux handicap
on est à peu près trois semaines après
la fameuse tempête de décembre 999 donc
les bois sont assez endommagés
les armes des sushis des toitures qui se
sont volées donc c'est vrai que bon il y
a eu des débris partout en plus c'est un
endroit où il y a beaucoup de décharges
sauvages donc on trouve tout un tas
d'objets que ce soit un vieux lave-linge
qu'on a acheté là mais aussi des
morceaux de bois cassés enfin tout un
tas de détritus et qu'on n'arrive pas à
faire le tri entre ce qui intéresse
l'affaire et ce qui est de l'ordre de
l'anecdote aucun témoignage peu
d'indices matériels les policiers Miss
désormais sur l'autopsie pour les aider
[Musique]
7 février 2000 à l'institut médico-légal
de Garches l'autopsie révèle les
premiers secrets du cadavre on s'est
quand même assez vite qu'il s'agit d'un
homme qui a une trentaine d'années on
arrive à faire une vague idée de sa
taille
il s'agit d'un individu de sexe masculin
mesurant environ un mètre 80 pesant
vraisemblablement aux alentours de 70 kg
âgé de 25 à 35 ans environ
autre constatation la mort est assez
récente elle remontrait à quelques jours
deux semaines maximum les médecins
légistes vont
faire un certain nombre de prélèvements
notamment dans le sang dans les viscères
et c'est l'analyse de l'estomac qui va
apporter une toute nouvelle information
une information qui s'avérera
particulièrement utile par la suite
un laboratoire de toxicologie à analyser
le sang et ce laboratoire a découvert la
présence d'un somnifère
aussitôt une question se pose l'homme
a-t-il absorbé ses médicaments de son
plein gré quelques minutes plus tard au
moment de disséquer les poumons de la
victime les légistes établissent les
circonstances exactes du meurtre on
retrouve à l'intérieur des poumons on
retrouve des suits
c'est à dire des traces d'inhalation de
l'incendie de la fumée et ça c'est très
important parce que ça signifie une
chose c'est que pendant qu'il brûlait la
personne respirait ça signifie qu'il a
été brûlé vif
la carbonisation a eu lieu alors que la
victime était vivante la découverte du
cadavre fait apparaître que il a essayé
de s'agripper et on voit sa main qui
s'accroche à un bout de bois et à de
l'herbe probablement pour essayer de
remonter le talus donc on sait que la
victime est morte dans horrible
souffrance pour les médecins légistes
c'est donc la carbonisation qui est à
l'origine de la mort une chose est sûre
l'homme a dû agoniser pendant de longues
minutes
restez identifier le cadavre mais les
résultats des analyses se font attendre
alors les policiers vont procéder
autrement
pour tenter de mettre un nom sur la
victime les hommes de la brigade
criminelle de Versailles n'ont qu'une
solution
étudier l'ensemble des disparitions
signalées ces derniers mois
travail fastidieux là encore pour les
enquêteurs puisque ils mettent les jours
et des jours à recouper des fiches et
par rapport à l'âge par rapport à la
taille par rapport à la description
physique enfin de tous les éléments qui
détiennent pour essayer de faire
recouper les choses après plusieurs
dizaines d'heures d'études les
enquêteurs repèrent une fiche qui
pourrait correspondre
ils vont se rendre compte que il y a une
personne qui a disparu alors qui est pas
une disparition véritablement c'est pas
si on disparition c'est quelqu'un qui
aurait quitté le domicile conjugal il
s'agirait d'un homme de 37 ans
disparu depuis une quinzaine de jours et
il s'agirait d'un certain Joël Desprez
les enquêteurs ne disposent que de cette
vieille photo de Joël Desprez au service
militaire mais tout indique qu'ils sont
sur la bonne piste le signalement
correspond l'âge la tranche d'âge du
cadavre qui se trouve entre 30 et 50
encore correspond la taille correspond
donc ils vont sortir cette fiche et puis
pousser un peu plus loin les
investigations cet homme ce joël dépress
est un père de famille qui a fait 5
enfants qui sont âgés à l'époque de 3 4
5 7 et 11 ans
et c'est un déménageur qui travaille en
Seine-Saint-Denis pour savoir si le
cadavre appartient bien à ce Joël des
prêts une comparaison de la dentition
est effectuée les résultats ne laissent
plus de place au doute et bon bah cette
comparaison dentaire elle va être
implacable elle va dire voilà le cadavre
d'errani qui se trouve sur les bords de
l'Oise c'est le cas là de Monsieur
Desprez
[Musique]
donc là à partir de ce moment là les
policiers ils ont un nom qui est
fondamental dans les enquêtes donc là
ils peuvent commencer véritablement à
chercher ce qui s'est passé
72 heures après la découverte du corps
les policiers se rendent à Franconville
pour annoncer à Nathalie Després la
femme de Joël la mort de son mari
ils ont apporté avec eux l'une des
chaussures trouvées sur la scène de
crime leur but tenter de trouver un
début d'explication
comme élément de reconnaissance on a pu
se prélever une chaussure qui n'est pas
trop spontanée par les feux et qui
pense-t-on va pas trop choquer quand
même l'épouse puisque à ce moment-là on
est dans une démarche d'annonce d'un
décès
c'est au commandant Jean-Louis
guillonneuf que revient la tâche
difficile d'annoncer à Nathalie Desprès
la terrible nouvelle la porte nous a
ouverte par une dame qui se présente
comme étant Madame Nathalie Després je
lui présente la chaussure que l'on a
récupéré sur le corps elle marque un
temps d'arrêt un choc un choc
psychologique je comprends à ce
moment-là que
elle elle vient de recevoir une annonce
une annonce
traumatisante
Nathalie Desprez est effondré mais les
policiers doivent l'interroger il la
conduisent au commissariat
la jeune femme leur raconte avoir vu son
mari pour la dernière fois trois
semaines avant le drame c'était le 21
janvier 2000
Nathaniel raconte une disparition qui
n'a rien d'inquiétant elle se souvient
de l'avoir entendu partir le matin la
même vue en tenue de déménageurs
puisqu'il travaille dans le dans une
société de déménagement
[Musique]
le vendredi 21 janvier mon mari est
parti au travail avec son véhicule R18
il est parti vers 6h15 comme tous les
matins
[Musique]
pour elle la dernière fois qu'elle l'a
vu il partait travailler
et elle comprend pas ce qui a pu lui
arriver
Nathalie précise que depuis sa
disparition elle a tenté de nombreuses
fois de joindre son mari
la plaie à plusieurs reprises elle a
envoyé des messages des textos sans
aucune réponse il est parti avec sa
voiture et depuis il a disparu corsé
bien sans nouvelles de Joël quelques
jours après sa disparition Nathalie
Desprez a signalé à la police un abandon
de domicile conjugal car depuis
plusieurs mois explique-t-elle leur
couple allait très mal d'ailleurs à la
grande surprise des enquêteurs la veuve
dresse un portrait très négatif de son
ex-mari son épouse le décrit comme un
homme extrêmement possessif jaloux
buveur excessif et qui pouvait dit-elle
se montrer violent à son égard
il buvit des bières et du pastis cela
suffisait pour qu'il est un comportement
agressif vis-à-vis de moi et des enfants
il les insultait mais ne les frappaient
pas
lors d'une dispute mon mari m'a retourné
le poignet pour m'empêcher de partir de
l'appartement
Nathalie Desprez ne s'arrête pas là elle
explique qu'elle avait décidé d'entamer
une procédure de divorce c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
l'absence soudaine de son mari ne
l'avait pas particulièrement inquiété
Nathalie
argumente la disparition de son mari de
Joël Desprez en disant vous coûter on
était en étant instance de divorce je
pense qu'il a simplement voulu prendre
l'air un peu respirer
faire le point c'est vrai qu'au début il
était pas très pas très pour cette
histoire de divorce et puis finalement
il a l'air de ce qu'il y a de fait et
d'ailleurs pourquoi il est parti
Nathalie desprées explique aux
enquêteurs que les problèmes du couple
ont débuté en 1996 lorsqu’après 12 ans
de mariage et quatre enfants elle est de
nouveau tombée enceinte Nathalie
on ne veut pas cet enfant elle ne veut
pas le garder elle ne souhaite pas le
garder et c'est Joël qui insiste elle
explique que la cinquième la petite
Laura n'était pas prévue que elle elle
n'en avait pas envie qu'elle n'avait pas
envie d'être une cinquième fois enceinte
d'avoir une cinquième enfant et ce n'est
pas tout l'attention au sein du couple
était également alimenté par des
finances désastreuses le couple des
presque un couple qui a des difficultés
financières certaine qui vit de façon
assez chiche avec peu de revenus puisque
Nathalie des prêts ne travaille pas ils
ont cinq enfants je vais le déprime et
déménageurs avec un salaire qui est
assez modeste alors le couple est
interdit bancaire depuis 1993 et c'est
la raison pour laquelle Joël fait des
extras en marge de son de son emploi de
déménageur dans la sécurité c'est une
situation financière extrêmement
compliquée dans la mesure où il y a il y
a cette bouche à nourrir à la maison
un mariage qui bat de l'aile une
séparation programmée tout naturellement
les enquêteurs se demandent si Nathalie
Després à un amant
[Musique]
dit d'ailleurs elle parle de plusieurs
de plusieurs aventures d'une première
puis d'une deuxième
Nathalie des précaution dans sa vie il
s'appelle Stéphane esry c'est un agent
de sécurité au chômage de 29 ans c'est
aussi un ancien collègue de son mari
Stéphane et Joël sont collègues de
travail puis amis c'est par ce biais que
Stéphane va rencontrer Nathalie il
s'invite chez les uns chez les autres et
puis
très rapidement cette relation va
déraper il y a un véritable coup de
foudre entre Nathalie et Stéphanie et
ils vont très rapidement donc devenir
amant tout le monde le sait sauf Joël
tout ça se passe dans son dos en effet
Nathalie Desprez précise que son mari
Joël n'était au courant de rien
l'information paraît d'autant plus
incroyable aux enquêteurs qu'ils
découvrent que le mari et l'amant ne se
partagait pas seulement la même femme
les policiers vont découvrir que
Stéphane estery donc l'amant de Nathalie
non seulement il est l'amant de Nathalie
mais en plus ça il vit à Franconville au
domicile de Joël Desprez de Joël et
Nathalie
en plus de leurs cinq enfants Joël
Després son épouse Nathalie et l'amant
de cette dernière Stéphane esprit
cohabite avec une quatrième personne
Sandrine ESRI qui n'est autre que la
femme de Stéphane
sandrine est là la preuve épouse de
Stéphane et qu'elle par cohabiter
également avec les dépress dans cet
appartement
les policiers n'en reviennent pas le
mari sa femme l'amant et la femme de
l'amant vivent sous le même toit
Nathalie va tenter d'expliquer aux
policiers c'est incroyable situation
pour elle il ne s'agissait que de rendre
service
dans cet appartement de Franconville les
SRI arrivent parce qu'ils ont été
expulsés de leur appartement tout le
monde a donc emménagé dans le 4 pièces
des déprés je précise d'ailleurs que
c'est un petit appartement et d'ailleurs
les enfants ils sont cinq de Joël et
Nathalie les enfants vont se retrouver à
7 puisqu'il y aura les deux enfants de
Sandrine et de Stéphane dans une même
chambre ce qui fait peu d'espace et donc
ils étaient vraiment les uns sur les
autres avec une importante promiscuité à
la fin de l'audition de Nathalie les
policiers sont face à une situation qui
frise le cocasse là les policiers
commencent à se poser quand même
sérieusement les questions voilà quand
on est dans un petit quatre pièces qu'on
a un type qui a disparu que sa femme
couche avec le copain qui est venu
s'installer avec sa femme
en une seule audition les enquêteurs
découvrent trois suspects Nathalie
Després qui ne supportait plus son mari
Stéphane hessery qui aurait pu vouloir
se débarrasser de son concurrent et même
Sandrine la femme de Stéphane qui
acceptait cette étrange situation
alors les policiers décident d'entendre
l'amant et sa compagne
les enquêteurs convoquent Sandrine et
Stéphane
pour commencer ils veulent vérifier la
véracité des propos de Nathalie Després
ils interrogent donc le couple
séparément
aider le début de son audition Stéphane
esprit reconnaît entretenir une relation
adultère avec Nathalie Després une
relation qui aurait débuté un mois avant
la mort de son mari
la première fois que j'ai eu un rapport
sexuel avec Nathalie c'était le 21
décembre 1999 dans la journée quand Joël
était au travail il n'en a jamais rien
su il ne nous a jamais surpris
plus surprenant encore Sandrine esprit
la femme de Stéphane ne semble pas se
formaliser de la relation
extra-conjugale de son mari allons
croire elle était au courant depuis bien
longtemps elle nous explique que elle ne
s'en est pas offusquée parce que
elle-même n'a plus de relations
sentimentale avec lui et elle nous
confirme également que
Joël Desprez n'était pas au courant de
la liaison contre tenez son épouse avec
Monsieur ESRI
les policiers interrogent également le
couple esprit sur la personnalité de
Joël Després leur but corroborer le
portrait d'homme violent que Nathalie
des prêts adressé de son mari pour
Stéphane hessri l'homme était
particulièrement agressif
[Musique]
Joël n'arrêtait pas de gueuler sur sa
femme et des fois il levait la main sur
elle il l'a traitait de il traitait
aussi ses enfants de bâtard et de fils
de
[Musique]
Stéphane esprit Bros c'est un portrait
extrêmement noir de Joël selon ses
déclarations Joël et quelqu'un qui bat
son épouse qui la viole qui est
extrêmement violent avec les enfants
avec les cinq enfants
et Nathalie serait donc une femme une
femme battue de son côté Sandrine esprit
fait la même description de Joël des
Prés
c'était un garçon qui était
plutôt plutôt violent qui avait tendance
à abuser de la boisson et elle nous en
dresse un portrait plutôt négatif
enfin Sandrine esprit confirme les
propos de Nathalie Deprez elle aussi a
entendu Joël partir travailler le jour
de sa disparition de partie après avoir
pris ses vêtements pour son travail ses
vêtements de déménageurs il est parti
travailler de bonheur 5h36 heures en
siffle le temps en tous les cas c'est ce
que dit Cendrillon
interroger individuellement Nathalie
Desprez Stéphane et Sandrine ESRI ont
donné aux enquêteurs la même version des
faits les policiers s'interrogent alors
qu'est-il arrivé au déménageur après
qu'il soit parti travailler ce matin-là
et c'est une contravention qui va leur
apporter un début de réponse
[Musique]
48 heures plus tard les enquêteurs
reçoivent un appel à l'autre bout du fil
la fourrière de Clichy-la-Garenne on
vient de leur apporter la voiture de
Joël Desprez elle était abandonnée
depuis 7 jours dans le centre ville
d'Épinay-sur-Seine à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de son domicile
[Musique]
les enquêteurs se rendent immédiatement
sur place
vois une vieille R18 en mauvais état de
carrosserie j'inspecte l'intérieur et
quelque chose me saute aux yeux un
élément de saute aux yeux je relève la
présence de debout une présence
importante debout sécher sur le tapis de
sol du de la place passager avant ce qui
implique très vite qu'on sait qu'il y a
au moins deux personnes qui sont montées
une au siège conducteurs ça ça paraît
assez logique et une sur le siège
passager ces deux personnes ont
fréquenté le même terrain un petit peu
boueux à l'époque d'où vient cette terre
s'agit-il de celle de la scène de crime
des échantillons sont prélevés pour
analyse
dans les heures qui suivent au
laboratoire de la police scientifique de
Paris des comparaisons sont effectuées
entre la terre trouvée dans la voiture
de Joël des Prés et celle qui a été
prélevée autour du corps les résultats
sont sans appel
sur les chaussures de la victime sur les
deux tapisols de la voiture de Joël
Desprez c'est la même terre
conclusion les criminels qui étaient au
moins deux ont emprunté le véhicule de
Joël des prêts pour quitter la scène du
meurtre
[Musique]
voilà donc là il commence quand même à
se dire que cette voiture elle a
peut-être servi à quelque chose de pas
terrible de pas très clair et qu'en tout
cas c'est une pièce fondamentale de leur
enquête
alors question pourquoi les meurtriers
ont-ils ensuite déposé la voiture à 26
km de la pour les policiers il n'y a
qu'une explication possible et à partir
de là ils ont déduisent assez
logiquement
qu'il y a eu une mise en scène
un peu difficilement imaginer que Joël
des prêts et conduit sa voiture pour la
ramener Épinay-sur-Seine alors qu'il est
brûlé dans un trou à Éragny donc ça veut
dire que voilà le corps a été transporté
par plusieurs personnes avec la voiture
de Joël desperesy-sur-oise et qu'après
bah ces personnes sont allés déposer la
voiture à Épinay
les policiers vont vite avoir la
confirmation de cette mise en scène
sordide si la voiture de Joël des prêts
a été stationnée à Épinay-sur-Seine ce
n'est pas par hasard la société
déménagement Joël dépress se trouve à
Épinay et sa voiture a duré 18 a été
retrouvé dans le centre dans le centre
ville d'épinières quelques kilomètres
même pas de du vieux de son travail les
criminels ont donc voulu faire croire
que l'homme avait disparu non loin de
son lieu de travail pour les enquêteurs
il devient urgent d'interroger
l'employeur de Joël des Prés
dans l'après-midi les enquêteurs
prennent la direction
d'épinais-sur-seine il se rendent dans
les locaux de la société de déménagement
pour laquelle travaillait Joël Desprez
[Musique]
c'est la patronne en personne qui leur
ouvre la porte et celle-ci va alors
révéler une information cruciale
antivons lui demander l'emploi du temps
je vais le prêt les jours où ils
travaillent les gens ils travaillaient
pas mais ils vont se rendre compte que
le fameux
le fameux jour où sa femme l'a vu partir
un matin avec sa tenue de déménagement
pour aller travailler Épinay-sur-Seine
bah ce genre les travailler Paris il a
épousé le vendredi et là ça sonne ça
coûte tonnerre dans l'enquête parce que
jusqu'à présent nathalie avait affirmé
que le 21 au matin il s'était habillé
vers 6h qu'il était parti travailler
avec sa voiture et là ils ont la preuve
qu'il n'a pas travaillé et plus
extraordinaire encore il a posé à
l'avance sa journée
pourquoi Nathalie Després et Sandrine
esprit ont-elles affirmé que Joël Deprez
était parti travailler ce matin-là pour
les policiers il n'y a que deux
possibilités
de deux choses l'une soit les deux
femmes mentent depuis le début soit Joël
aurait dit qu'il allait travailler et en
aurait profité pour pour partir pour
quitter son domicile mais les policiers
vont vite obtenir une réponse à leurs
questions car Joël Debré avait confié à
sa patronne ce qu'il avait prévu de
faire ce vendredi là
ce vendredi il avait rendez-vous avec
une agence bancaire pour ouvrir pour
ouvrir un compte et en contactant
l'agence bancaire on s'aperçoit que il
ne sait pas présenté le matin comme
prévu à ce rendez-vous d'ouverture de
compte
ce vendredi là Joël avait également pris
rendez-vous avec un avocat pour son
divorce après vérification il ne s'y est
pas rendu non plus
ces deux rendez-vous manqués
signifient-ils que Joël Desprez était
déjà mort ce vendredi pour l'heure
impossible de répondre et ce n'est pas
la seule question que soulève l'audition
de la patronne de Joël Desprez la
description quel dresse de la victime
n'a rien à voir avec les témoignages que
les policiers avaient jusque-là
recueilli
[Musique]
c'était un garçon gentil sérieux et
travailleur il ne m'a jamais donné
l'impression d'une personne ça donnant
la boisson
[Musique]
une version confirmée par l'enquête de
voisinage menée par l'APJ à Franconville
là où vivait Joël des prés des voisins
de l'immeuble des gens qui connaissent
un petit peu le couple font pas du tout
du tout du tout ce portrait là je
veulent des prêts bien au contraire elle
dit que c'est un type qui vit pour son
boulot qui part tôt le matin qui rentre
tard le soir qui n'a jamais été croisé
par qui que ce soit Yves qui fréquente
pas les bistrots du quartier plus les
policiers rencontrent les proches du
couple des Prés et plus les témoignages
coïncides Joël Desprez est un homme aimé
et serviable alors pourquoi sa femme a
tellement dit aux enquêteurs
d'autant qu'en interrogeant les voisins
les policiers découvrent que l'épouse se
vantait même de mener une vie d'enfer à
Joël des prés tout le quartier était au
courant Joël Després est devenu une
espèce de tête de turc la tête de turc
de tout ce petit monde Nathalie a
commencé à détester son mari au point de
l'humilier en public au point de
l'affibler de surnom ridicule de duconde
Bourvil
et
tous se vantaient de pouvoir faire faire
ce qu'il voulait ce qu'il voulait à Joël
et c'est vrai parce que Joël était prêt
à tout
c'est des blagues de très mauvais goût
l'hiver de guitare genre dans le café
au lycée à manger quand on a envie de
lui servir à manger on se moque de lui
dès qu'on peut se moquer de lui
grâce à tous ces témoignages les hommes
de la PJ comprennent alors la présence
de la liste de courses sur le cadavre
carbonisé Joël Desprez était l'homme à
tout faire et même la vache à lait du
foyer et puis découvre aussi que Joël et
ben finalement c'est le seul à
travailler dans la maison c'est lui qui
fait les courses que c'est lui qui fait
le ménage comment jouer le déprés a-t-il
pu accepter d'être humilié en permanence
par son épouse les voisins sont unanimes
l'homme aimait passionnément Nathalie
joël est un homme qui était éperdument
amoureux de sa femme et qui aimait
profondément ses enfants et qui s'est
laissé maltraiter c'est laisser appeler
du con c'est laisser appeler Bourvil
pour
pouvoir être prête sa femme et de ses
enfants pour les policiers ces auditions
agissent comme un détonateur Nathalie
Després Stéphane ESRI et Sandrine esprit
leur ont menti sur toute la ligne
pire encore les enquêteurs vont
découvrir que Joël des prêts avait fini
par comprendre que sa femme le trompait
ouvertement
parmi les personnes entendues les
enquêteurs interrogent un certain Gérard
Tomas le chef d'équipe de Joël Desprez à
l'entreprise de déménagement l'homme
explique que quelques jours avant sa
mort Joël déprp lui avait fait une
incroyable confession
la scène se passe le dimanche 16 janvier
à 6h du matin Joël rentre dans
l'appartement de Franconville après
avoir travaillé toute la nuit comme
vigile le dimanche matin il rentre du
travail fatigué et puiser là il rentre
tout doucement pour me réveiller
personne
[Musique]
et quand il pousse la Porte du de la
chambre conjugale il découvre sa femme
mais pas seule
il distingue deux formes dans son lit
celles de son épouse et puis d'un homme
à côté qui dort en caleçon elle est en
nuisette la nuisette assez relevée sur
le haut du corps et à ses côtés d'or
Stéphane ESRI
il va s'adresser à sa femme lui demander
ce que Stéphane fait dans le lit et sa
femme lui répond il dort
Stéphane lui répond qu'il s'est trompé
de lit ensuite il lui explique que qu'il
est venu bavarder avec Nathalie et puis
qui s'est endormi là enfin autant de
choses totalement incohérentes que que
personne ne peut croire même pas Joël
face à ses explications peu crédibles
Joël des prétentes malgré tout un geste
de réconciliation avec sa femme il va
chercher embrasser sa femme
c'est pas trop dans quel démarche mais
en tout cas pour lui dire qu'il lui en
veut pas qu'il l'aime toujours il va
récolter une paire de gifles
[Musique]
donc c'est un petit peu le monde à
l'envers
on essaye la gentillesse parfois
effectivement la violence on essaye tout
pour essayer de faire comprendre à
l'autre qu'on ne l'aime plus et il a du
mal à comprendre sous le choc Joël va
réveiller ses plus grands enfants âgés
de 8 et 11 ans et les fait venir dans la
chambre regardez regardez votre mère
regardez ce qu'elle me fait
et il s'effondre il s'effondrant là
il pleure il est désespéré les enfants
sont là ils sont prêts à témoin de cette
mère au lit pour les enfants c'est pas
non plus une surprise parce qu'on se
rend compte que les enfants ils savaient
[Musique]
Gérard Thomas le confident de Joël
Desprez assure aux enquêteurs que jusque
là son ami ne se doutait de rien là il y
a un élément de réalité qui fait qu'il
ne peut plus se voiler la face qui ne
peut plus faire semblant de ne pas
savoir et je pense que vraiment pour
pour intégrer ça pour y croire il faut
non seulement qu'il voit bien sûr mais
aussi qu'il fasse constater par ses
enfants fait qu'il est trompé là il y a
un point de Morteau qui est franchi
c'est-à-dire que là de façon définitive
et officielle
nathalie est avec Stéphane esprit je
vois des prêts peut même plus avoir
accès au lit conjugal à la chambre
conjugale chose incroyable selon le
collègue de Joël Desprez suite à cet
épisode l'homme décide de rester chez
lui et même de reconquérir sa femme il
va encore tout tenter pour essayer de
sauver son couple en offrant un cadeau à
son épouse c'est dire comme il aime que
Joël n'est prêt
reste là malgré tout ne s'en va pas ne
quitte pas le domicile continue à aimer
sa femme donc continue à être cette
espèce de c'est terrible à dire mais de
personnages un peu collants un peu voilà
qui accepte pas de céder sa place il
devient finalement un témoin gênant et
un obstacle au bonheur d'une femme qui
veut échapper à son ordinaire qui veut
échapper à son quotidien et qui a le
sentiment qu'elle peut refaire sa vie
d'autant qu'elle s'imagine que elle
pourra faire de Stéphane un père de
substitution grâce aux témoignages du
collègue de Joël Desprez les enquêteurs
disposent désormais d'un mobile pour eux
cela ne fait plus de doutes les deux
amants Nathalie Després et Stéphane ESRI
ont assassiné Joël Despré se marie
devenu gênant mais de nombreuses
questions restent sans réponse
ont-ils agissent seul Sandrine esprit
est-elle complice
en guise de réponse les policiers vont
bientôt voir apparaître dans cette
incroyable quatuor amoureux un nouveau
personnage
face à temps d’interrogation les hommes
de l'APJ décident de reprendre les
auditions des proches du couple et un
nom dans la déposition du propre frère
de Nathalie des prés va retenir leur
attention
la fois que j'ai vu jouer elle remonte
au jeudi précédent sa disparition
ce soir-là il y avait Stéphane et
Sandrine ESRI et William le Guillon
[Musique]
et bien louillian le Guillon et l'amant
de Sandrine Sandrine ESRI la femme de
Stéphane esry les enquêteurs ne sont pas
au bout de leur surprise ils vont
découvrir que William le Guyon vit lui
aussi chez les Desprez on a quand même
une citation qui est un petit peu
inédite les policiers sont pas là pour
porter des jugements moraux ou des
jugements de valeur sur la vie de chacun
mais il se rend compte quand même que
sous le même toit il y a Joël Desprez sa
femme
l'amant de sa femme la femme de la Manza
femme et l'amant de la femme de l'amant
de sa femme bon c'est assez compliqué à
comprendre et en tout cas c'est assez
intéressant pour que ça intrigue les
policiers qui se disent bon il y a
peut-être déjà quelque chose qui cloche
à ce niveau là et là d'un seul coup ça
devient plus clair quand même l'histoire
c'est à dire que c'est une sorte de
Eureka les policiers disent bah voilà ça
y est c'est bien sûr Joël ne voulait pas
entendre parler de divorce et à partir
de là ma foi ils sont pas compliqués la
vie à partir du moment où il voulait pas
divorcer
son sort était scellé d'autant qu'il les
avait surpris en flagrant délit il
fallait qu'il disparaisse
ces deux couples recomposés avaient donc
tout intérêt à se débarrasser de Joël
Desprez l'empêcheur de s'aimer en rond
donc les policiers commencent quand même
à se dire bon le scénario de nous dire
voilà il est parti travailler il a
disparu il est pas revenu ça colle pas
ça peut pas coller
on sait maintenant qu'il y a plusieurs
personnes qui se sont occupées
transportées le corps on sait donc qui a
eu un scénario qui a été monté puisqu'on
ne s'est donné la peine d'aller mettre
la voiture près d'un lieu où j'aurai
Desprez censé aller travailler les
enquêteurs ont une hypothèse
Joël Desprez serait rentré chez lui le
jeudi soir deux des protagonistes
l'auraient ensuite conduit dans sa
propre voiture à Eragny-sur-Oise pour le
brûler une fois le crime commis ils
auraient abandonné la voiture près du
travail de Joël à Épinay-sur-Seine pour
vérifier si leur hypothèse se tient les
policiers disposent d'un atout
considérable
[Musique]
les enquêteurs apprennent que la veille
de sa disparition Joël Després a conduit
sa voiture au garage
la fameuse R18 de Joël des prêts elle
sort du contrôle technique quasiment
donc ils savent de façon
mathématique que lorsqu'elle est rentrée
au contrôle technique quelques heures
avant que Joël dépress disparaisse elle
avait tant de kilomètres et que quand il
a retrouvé à Épinay elle a à peu près je
crois une cinquantaine de kilomètres en
plus d'après le calcul des policiers la
R18 à 13 exactement parcouru 47,9 km à
quoi correspond cette distance les
enquêteurs vont prendre leur propre
voiture et refaire ce qu'il pense être
le trajet de la R18 la nuit du crime
les policiers vont refaire le chemin ils
vont refaire le parcours
du garage ou le contrôle technique a été
effectué ils vont aller à Franconville
au domicile de Joël des prés ensuite ils
vont se rendre sur les lieux du crime
puis ils vont se rendre là où on
retrouve le véhicule à Épinay-sur-Seine
[Musique]
le résultat du kilométrage semble à
peine croyable
47,9 km exactement la même distance que
le trajet qu'aurait effectué la voiture
de Joël des prêts
pour les policiers c'est une petite
victoire leur hypothèse colle
parfaitement
on a le chemin du véhicule et le chemin
des assassins
[Musique]
les policiers disposent désormais d'une
conviction forte mais toujours pas de
preuve à eux désormais de déterminer
l'emploi du temps des quatre suspects au
moment du crime
Nathalie Després William le Guillon
Stéphane et Sandrine ESRI affirme être
resté à l'appartement des déprés le soir
de la mort de Joël pour vérifier leur
alibi les enquêteurs examinent la
téléphonie du quattoir la fameuse nuit
du 20 au 21 janvier il y a trois appels
qui sont passés entre 1h et demi du
matin et 2h du matin à peu près et
évidemment le fait de pouvoir retracer
ces trois appels ça permet aussi de les
géolocaliser
chaque appel passait avec un téléphone
portable active un volet téléphonique il
le borne comme on le dit dans le métier
et la géolocalisation des appels de
Stéphane Escrive va prouver que l'homme
a menti
à 1h43 et à 1h44 du matin
Stéphane esprit appelle Nathalie là il
borne sur Franconville
et il y a un dernier appel qui est à
deux heures 06 qui lui borne sur Éragny
c'est à dire sur les lieux du crime les
horaires des appels coïncident avec
l'heure de la mort de Joël des Prés
en effet souvenez-vous la montre
carbonisée s'était arrêtée à deux orquin
on peut donc facilement supposer que
Stéphane estery a appelé Nathalie
Desprez juste avant ou juste après avoir
participé à l'assassinat de Joël
physiquement la téléphonie permet
d'établir
la présence de Stéphane hesstry à la
fois à Franconville et surtout sur les
lieux du crime c'est-à-dire à Éragny
10 mai 2000 à l'aube Nathalie Desprez et
Stéphane esprit sont arrêtés ensemble
au même moment à Aulnay-sous-Bois
Sandrine escrier William le Guillon sont
conduits à la direction régionale de la
police judiciaire de Versailles
[Musique]
et aider les premières minutes les
enquêteurs sentent que la jeune femme
est sur le point de craquer
Sandrine elle est très mal tout de suite
parce que dès que les policiers la
montent dans la voiture pour l'emmener
au commissariat pour l'entendre elle est
je crois qu'ils sentent qu'elle est
quasiment prête à parler déjà dans la
voiture dans la voiture
on sait très bien que t'as rien fait on
sait très bien que tu es pas si on sait
très bien que tu as pas participé
dis-nous la vérité
7h15 commissariat premier procès-verbal
je vais vous dire la vérité
arrivé au siège de la PJ Sandrine
racontant en détail ce qu'elle sait de
la faire
[Musique]
tout commence dans l'appartement de
Franconville le mardi 18 janvier deux
jours seulement après que Joël des prêts
a découvert sa femme au lit avec
Stéphane esprit
Sandrine raconte que ce jour-là elle
entend parler pour la première fois du
macabre projet se débarrasser de Joël
des Prés
[Musique]
Stéphane a dit j'en ai marre il faut
qu'on tue Joël il a dit que Nathalie
avait donné son feu vert mais qu'il ne
savait pas comment faire je n'étais pas
d'accord je voulais partir avec les
enfants mais Stéphane m'a menacé
le lendemain Sandrine aperçoit Stéphane
esprit s'entretenir avec William le
Guillon il sait que cet ancien soldat
peut trouver le moyen d'éliminer Joël
des prêts
[Musique]
la guerre du Golf il a fait il a été il
a opéré également Kosovo et cette espèce
un peu dorade dans l'ancien militaire
reconversi dans la sécurité
ce quelqu'un qui physiquement c'est
imposant à l'époque c'est lui qui va
essayer d'affiner un peu le mode
opératoire en disant voilà il y a
plusieurs solutions soit on utilise une
arme à feu soit en égorge après de toute
façon faudra se débarrasser du corps
donc pourquoi pas le brûler
24 heures plus tard le 20 janvier
Sandrine raconte qu'en passant devant la
cuisine elle surprend un curieux manège
Sandrine comprend ce que c'est ce soir
là que ça va se passer elle comprend que
c'est ce soir-là que ça va se passer
parce qu'elle voit Stéphane en train de
broyer les cachets de l'examine et les
mélanger à la nourriture
[Musique]
Stéphane essri écrase plusieurs
comprimés du puissant anxiolytique
tandis que Nathalie des prés prépare un
boeuf en sauce
c'est dans ce plat que ce reverser la
poudre de médicaments Sandrine raconte
ensuite que vers 21h Joël Després rentre
de son contrôle technique la bonne
humeur règne dans l'appartement et
pourtant le plan machiavélique est
enclenché il y a une ambiance assez
festive d'ailleurs tout le monde est
assez joyeux on fume un peu de cannabis
on boit un peu d'alcool etc donc Joël
voilà comme c'est le bon gars il boit un
peu d'alcool aussi fume un petit peu
pour la première fois depuis fort
longtemps et bien Nathalie joue l'épouse
modèle elle lui prépare lui réchauffe
son assiette et d'ailleurs entre
Stéphane et elle il s'applique autour de
lui à ce qu'il mange convenablement et
pour cause l'assiette de boeuf en sauce
contient la forte dose d'anxiolytique
qu'ils ont écrasés
mais comme il sentait quelque chose Joël
s'arrête bientôt de manger
il commence son assiette de bœuf en
sauce mais très vite il a plus faim il y
en a trop dans l'assiette et il veut
plus manger il veut s'arrêter là
d'habitude on se foutait un peu de ce
qui pouvait faire ou ne pas faire mais
là stéphanie est pas très content parce
qu'il voudrait bien qu'ils finissent
quand même son assiette de bœuf en sauce
donc on le force quasiment à manger le
cocktail d'alcool de cannabis et de
médicaments fait rapidement son effet
Joël n'est déjà plus dans son état
normal le mélange est étonnant chez
quelqu'un qui qui déjà supporte pas
l'alcool alors comment ça délirer il
parle de bête verte enfin il a lucide
puis finit par laisser s'affaler sur un
canapé dans le salon qui s'endort un
espèce de semis consciente on sait pas
s'il est sous si c'est le cannabis si
c'est des hommes il s'est probablement
un peu Détroit il est presque minuit et
la première partie du stratagème s'est
déroulée comme prévu maintenant on va
pouvoir passer à la deuxième phase des
opérations telles que ça a été pensé par
notamment le duo ESRI le Guillon et bien
ils l'ont changé ils l'ont habillé en
tenue de travail puis on va le
transporter puisqu'il peut plus marcher
tout seul c'est Nathalie qui tient la
porte elle dira n'oubliez pas laisser
les chaussures de sécurité ce qu'il faut
rendre le scénario crédible qu'il est
parti au travail si on laisse les
chaussures de sécurité ici ça va pas ils
l'ont descendu dans l'ascenseur l'une
tenant la porte l'autre aidant enfin
bref tout le monde a participé puis
après on va le sortir on va le mettre
dans le coffre de la R18
le récit de Sandrine s'arrête là elle
n'en sait pas plus puisqu'elle est
restée à la maison mais les enquêteurs
disposent maintenant d'assez d'éléments
pour interroger les autres suspects
c'est des avait en cascade la police
savait que c'était le maillon faible et
à partir de ce moment-là ils vont
interroger William grâce à
l'interrogatoire de William le Guillon
l'amant de Sandrine ESRI les policiers
sont en mesure de reconstituer la suite
des événements le moment où il a fallu
se débarrasser de Joël Desprez qui se
trouve dans le coffre de la voiture
William prend le volant de cette Renault
18 tandis que Stéphane lui va suivre
avec sa voiture personnelle le convoi
est en route il s'arrête dans une pompe
à essence prendre quatre litres
d'essence avec
Joël dans le coffre avec Joël dans le
coffre vivant
et donc on se retrouve sur le chemin de
halage il est on est en pleine nuit il
est à peu près une heure une heure et
demie deux heures du matin et donc là il
repère il repère un trou naturel entre
guillemets dans le dans le sol
c'est William qui est le plus costaud
qui va sortir le corps inanimé endormi
de Joël
il va le pousser dans le trou
[Musique]
Stéphane déverse le produit inflammable
essence sur le corps
allume
chiffon imbibé d'essence
[Musique]
il le jette comme ça le corps prend feu
rendu inconscient par le cocktail
d'alcool et d'anxiolytique Joël des prés
se transforme rapidement en torche
vivante
Stéphane reste quelques minutes à
regarder son rival
se recroqueviller sous la chaleur
[Musique]
tandis que William s'éloigne
ils ont brûlé le corps ils passent un
coup de fil Stéphane estery à Nathalie
Després et il dit voilà c'est fait on
est tranquille on est débarrassé enfin
voilà c'est vraiment ça y est on a ça
fait tellement de temps que ce qu'on
aurait dû le faire que là voilà ça y est
on se problème là on ne l'a plus quoi
il repartent en marche arrière pour
aller déposer notamment le R18 à
Épinay-sur-Seine et donc on laisse le
corps on laisse le corps flamber et se
consumer après doucement dans le trou à
5h du matin les deux hommes reviennent
et tout le monde se met d'accord sur la
façon dont a disparu Joël il est rentré
ivre la veille au soir
et reparti travailler le lendemain matin
comme d'habitude mais ce que les
criminels ignorent c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas acheté suffisamment d'essence le
corps de Joël n'a donc pas brûlé
entièrement 15 jours plus tard il sera
retrouvé par les chasseurs
[Musique]
21 octobre 2002 plus de 2 ans et demi
après la mort de Joël dépress ouvre le
procédé 4 accusés à la cour d'assises du
Val-d'Oise
d'entrée de jeu à la surprise générale
Nathalie des prés revient sur ses aveux
et se pose en victimes Nathalie
[Musique]
elle elle est victime de ce Stéphane
qu'elle a cru aimé qu'il a tellement
trahi et qui en plus assassiner son mari
le père de ses enfants
on hallucine de voir latitude qu'elle a
le président de la cour d'assises décide
alors de confronter Nathalie Després à
ses contradictions
face à de ces dénégations le président
Hayat lui a lu son PV d'audition Jean
madame vous nous dites aujourd'hui vous
n'avez rien fait que vous n'y êtes pour
rien que c'est lui que c'est l'autre etc
mais vous avez pas toujours dit ça
au début on garde la vue vous avez dit
ça c'était un soulagement sa mort nous a
soulagé on revivait on repartait sur
d'autres bases etc est-ce que vous
maintenez
cela il y a un silence de mort dans la
salle et d'une toute petite voix elle
baisse la tête elle fait
et elle s'évanne
[Musique]
elle a fini par reconnaître ce qui était
voilà ce qui était de toute façon une
évidence depuis le début mais ce qu'elle
essayait de contourner depuis
l'ouverture du procès pire encore d'été
moins vont raconter à la barre latitude
de Nathalie Hollande de l'assassinat de
son mari
c'est dans l'enquête que non seulement
elle boit la bouteille de champagne que
son marin avait ramener quelques jours
avant en quelque sorte pour fêter sa
mort enfin c'est pas autre chose que ça
et que ce soir là elle va passer des
coups de fil sur le portable de son mari
dont elle sait qu'il est mort qu'il est
brûlé et elle doit lui passer des coups
de fil en disant te garde une assiette
on t'attend on garde une coupe de
champagne etc les accusés ne peuvent
plus se dérober à présent reste à
déterminer leur responsabilité
chacun seul n'aurait jamais échafaudé un
pareil scénario mais on écarte et
finalement les responsabilités
apparaissent un peu dilué ce qui fait de
ce groupe un quatuor on a dit
diaboliques
après seulement trois jours de procès le
jury se retire pour délibérer
24 octobre 2002 3 heures de délibéré
auront suffit le verdict tombe
Stéphane esrié Coop de la prison à
perpétuité une condamnation qui sera
réduite à 30 ans en appel
30 ans de réclusion également pour
William le Guillon et Nathalie Després
à l'énoncé de sa sentence la jeune femme
s'effondre
concernant Sandrine ESRI en tant que
simple complice elle n'écope que de 8
ans de réclusion
[Musique]
seul à avoir été libéré la jeune femme à
divorcer de Stéphane ESRI en prison
depuis elle a refait sa vie
[Musique]